Irene bloom rad who is someone who
studies identity citizenship immigration
is going to make the case that you are
actually your citizenship and I think
she's got a broad definition of what
citizenship is Irene is a Canadian who
now resides in California where she's an
associate professor of sociology at the
University of California she studies the
nexus of immigration politics and
national identities please welcome Irene
bloom rad who will answer the question
who are you by making the case that you
are your citizenship an interesting
thing on day like today you ask
Canadians their sense of belonging and
their pride in a Canadian identity and
in being Canadian nine out of ten
roughly residents of Canada say that
they feel like they belong to Canada and
they're proud of being Canadian or a
resident of Canada now that's an
incredibly high number like think of
what would happen if nine out of ten
Canadians agreed on taxes or nine out of
ten Canadians agreed on environmental
policy and that number is even more
remarkable when we think that about one
in five Canadians was not born in this
country so one of the remarkable things
I think about that statistic is that not
only does it apply for people with
long-standing roots in this country but
it also applies to people whose parents
immigrated to this country and to people
who have themselves grown up in another
land and moved to Canada and so what I
think that does is it gives us an
opening to ask what is it about the
Canadian context that allows us to even
answer this question I am my citizenship
in a way that 9 out of 10 Canadians will
more or less agree that I am Canadian so
if you look at what constitutes Canadian
identity this is based on a pole that
the environics Institute did in 2010 you
find that health care is really
prominent that over eighty percent of
while answering this survey said that
healthcare is strongly associated with
an identity as Canadian the Charter of
Rights and Freedoms is a significant
source of identity or something that
reflects Canadian identity the flag and
the national parks and the interesting
thing about these four items that are
sort of topping the list i think is if
you cast your mind back 50 years ago and
you imagine what people might have
answered to the question of Canadian
identity 50 years ago at least three of
these four wouldn't have been there
because they didn't exist now why is
this important this is important because
when I said that these people who are
cold in these opinion polls respond to
these ways these are all residents of
Canada which as many of you probably
know includes about twenty percent of
the population of Canada that was not
born in this country so you have a very
significant foreign born population that
was born somewhere else maybe spent some
years growing up there come to Canada
and then they respond in ways that are
very similar to these responses of all
other Canadians who are maybe born in
this country why does this matter in the
context of identity over the last year
especially we've been having lots of
debates around multiculturalism and
pluralism and many of you might remember
back in October the Chancellor of
Germany and Angela Merkel she made
headlines when she pronounced that
multiculturalism had utterly failed in
Germany she was not the only one Nicolas
Sarkozy the president of France made
similar statements in just a few months
ago David Cameron the Prime Minister of
Great Britain announced or he stated
that state multiculturalism was a
problem that even if Britain you know
respected diversity
a good thing the government should not
be involved in instead should embrace a
muscular liberalism in its place and
Canada has not been immune to this The
Globe and Mail came out with a editorial
that followed up on a series that had
been doing and as you can see here the
globe's editorial said multiculturalism
should be struck from the national
vocabulary Canada needs to have the
courage to build a successful society
around the concept of citizenship a lot
of people are wondering whether the
increased diversity that comes with
immigration diversity of language of
cultures backgrounds races ethnicities
religions whether that diversity is
undermining citizenship does more
diversity mean less citizenship and
citizenship here understood as cohesion
common projects common endeavors in the
future and one of the central arguments
of my research is that policies around
pluralism diversity multiculturalism
rather than presenting that as a
zero-sum trade-off more diversity less
citizenship actually bring those two
things together and allows diversity to
become a benefit within the context of
citizenship so that we have common
citizenship now what I want to do is I
want to give you a little bit of
evidence from some research I did based
on a Canada u.s. comparison and so if
you look with using census data
comparing the proportion of immigrants
foreign-born individuals who take up
either Canadian or American citizenship
across the 20th century so across the
sweep of that century from about 1900 up
to nineteen seventy they're pretty
similar but following 1970-71 something
remarkable starts happening the canadian
numbers keep inching up more and more
immigrants take out citizenship and the
u.s. numbers dropped immigrants in
canada over the last 10 to 20 years are
much more likely to take out Canadian
citizen
than American citizenship and this
really speaks that I think the answer to
the question of identity and who we are
the Canadian context citizenship is very
very important so one of the things that
you find when you look at sort of
immigrants in the united states and
canada is immigrants in the united
states and canada both have a similar
perception of social inclusion and also
the challenges of social inclusion so in
both Canada and the United States a lot
of immigrants especially in big cities
will say you know this society tolerates
and even recognizes my background I can
be Vietnamese Canadian I can be a
Vietnamese American and so on the ground
the social reality is similar in the US
and Canada but when it comes to the
political standing of those minorities
and their ability to advance political
projects or even just to say hey I'm
here you know think about me and and and
can you please speak to some of the
issues that are dear to my heart in
Canada you have more of that
incorporation than in the United States
public policy influences our notion of
citizenship our notation of membership
and our notion of standing in a society
so what's really important I think to
highlight when you ask the core when we
when I answer the question I am my
citizenship is I am highlighting I am a
reflection of the policies of my
government and the policies of my
society that give me a sense of who I am
in that society and that sort of bundled
together under the label of citizenship
the other reason that it's important
though is that I think citizenship
especially in democratic countries is
extremely important to give people the
sense of power that they can make
changes to their society and citizenship
is an important way for us to mobilize
identities to do things in the future
fundamentally integration into a society
is about the social connections we have
those social interactions and it can be
with organizations it can be with
community leaders churches religious
organizations etc they facilitate that
process of citizenship and so I'm going
to give you some examples of that in a
second that infrastructure the support
of infrastructure of community
organizations is fundamentally helped
along by things such as settlement
policy integration policy
multiculturalism policies so the policy
infrastructure provides a foundation
upon which immigrant communities can
mobilize themselves they can do their
own things they do their own stuff but
especially for immigrant communities
that might not have the same resources
might not come with a lot of financial
capital might not come with a lot of
education because where they came from
they didn't really have the opportunity
to go very far they really need sort of
this seed money let's say to help them
get integrated and also get on the path
of citizenship and then finally the
final point I'd like to make is that
public policy it's important for
instrumental reasons having a room
available for people to meet so that
they can talk about something in the
local library is fundamentally important
for helping this process along but it's
also the symbolic notions behind
policies the policies in place obviously
do things they give money they
you know they do technical things they
set up regulations but those policies
also in the minds of people represent
things and if you want additional
evidence beyond the immigrant case just
think of that first or the second
statistic I showed you about healthcare
you know who would have thought that
someone's identity as a Canadian would
be linked to whether you have health
insurance or not but clearly that is the
case in Canada so policies carry these
identity components with them which then
builds this bundle of citizenship I
interviewed Doris Meissner who was the
Commissioner for the immigration and
naturalization service when that still
existed on with the Clinton
administration she is probably one of
the inas commissioners who were most
dedicated to citizenship she wanted to
put the end back in i ns she was going
to put naturalization at the forefront
it didn't work out that way she actually
started the increase in the border
control in the United States and when
she reflected back and her time as an AI
NS Commissioner she said the dominant
culture of the agency is rooted in a
view of immigration as a source of
security and law enforcement
vulnerability more than of continued
nation-building currently in the United
States immigration and naturalization
services are within the Department of
Homeland Security and just by the name
of that agency you can imagine that that
hasn't really changed in the Canadian
case I interviewed some senior officials
at Citizenship and Immigration I took a
sort of standard American line and said
why are using taxpayer dollars to do all
of this citizenship stuff and the woman
I spoke to got quite upset with me and
said why would we not encourage
citizenship we say everyone belongs that
we believe in diversity when we promote
citizenship let's be clear it talks
about applying yes but at its beginning
it's about integration and this kind of
attitude immigrants get this but they
understand what's going on so with an
interview that I did with a Portuguese
American
who is low income in the Boston area she
was complaining about rents and she said
but they the government don't know how
it is you can't say sir Sir send the
people that care about the immigrants
because they are the people who can't
speak up there is nowhere to complain to
and we can't complain so very much a
feeling of being shut out in this other
case Joe was a really interesting person
because he had deep attachments to
Portugal and he actually held both
Canadian and American citizenship and I
asked him what you know who are you I
guess I asked him who are you you know
what are you and he said I'm Canadian
and I said well why are you Canadian why
not these other things he said well I
like the way the government runs things
I guess the great support the
multi-culture stuff the social
assistance we pay a lot of tax that's
true but the great concern of government
the help for the citizens themselves and
so he felt much more included in
government and in the citizenry so when
you know you can imagine Joe having to
answer this question about do you feel
you belong and he would be one of those
nine out of ten residents of Canada and
say yeah I do feel like I belong
you know fundamentally my research is
saying that public policies matter when
it comes to immigrant incorporation into
political systems and into citizenship
and that those public policies have to
provide both instrumental supports to
immigrants so that they can become part
of society and be active in civil
society and it has to provide a sense of
symbolic citizenship and a sense of
symbolic openness to who they are and
where they come from and in countries
that are able to bring both support to
immigrant communities and settlement
assistance together with this message
that we recognize and we appreciate you
in those countries immigrants are more
likely to participate and more likely to
be part of the things that we think of a
citizenship in terms of participating in
local schools running for office getting
together with others to solve problems
and even taking to the streets to
protest when they don't like what's
going on if you look at perceived
discrimination the unitary countries
those are countries that really try to
have a unitary notion of belonging
immigrants in those countries are more
likely to perceive discrimination so
they're more likely to see
discrimination visiter themselves
compared to the pluralist places the
places that have more diversity policies
more open citizenship and if you ask
about political trust trust in political
institutions trust in politicians the
ones who are in the more pluralist
societies are more likely to feel a
little bit more likely to feel trust in
those institutions and politicians than
the ones in the more unitary societies
or the societies where the notion of
citizenship is very unitary but I was
also argued to get back to the very
first point public policy really matters
in constituting our identities and in
the Canadian case it's an identity that
does have important links to public
policies not only multiculturalism but
things like health care national parks
etc and then the answer to who we are is
we are citizenship thank you very much
you